buenas tardes como hemos escuchado el
secretario general de la otan james
stoltenberg ha advertido de un ataque a
gran escala en ucrania stoltenberg cree
que moscú está pasando de esfuerzos
encubiertos de solo desestabilizar a
ucrania pero que ahora se está pasando a
una guerra abierta entre estos dos
países una acción militar aclara ha
asegurado no obstante stoltenberg ha
pedido que se reconduzca la situación
que nunca es tarde y que la vía
diplomática puede volverse a reconducir
y que incluso ha dicho ha pedido a rusia
que se siente encima de la mesa para
poder hablar y negociar no se ha
advertido claramente que la situación
actual en europa de su seguridad está
más amenazada que nunca en los últimos
años y hasta el momento que se sabe de
las sanciones que en estos momentos
están decididos de los cancilleres de la
unión europea
si los cancilleres europeos están
reunidos en parís de momento los
embajadores esta mañana aquí en bruselas
y ya han preparado el terreno en que
piden que por ejemplo individuos que
hayan participado en el reconocimiento
en la independencia de donets y lugares
que sean sancionados aquí se estudia por
ejemplo sancionar a los diputados de la
duma que votaron este reconocimiento
también sanciones a bancos sanciones
también financieras para evitar que el
kremlin y también en rusia pueda entrar
en los mercados financieros y de
servicios de la unión europea así como
dificultar el comercio la exportación y
la importación de productos a través de
estas regiones la unión europea insiste
en que va a actuar con unidad ante estas
sanciones se espera que se puedan entrar
en vigor en las próximas 48 horas estará
usted muchas gracias por esta ampliación
estamos muy pendientes de lo que pueda
ocurrir